con esta primera invitada del día vamos
a analizar las implicaciones del embargo
al petróleo ruso por parte de la Unión
Europea y el tope al precio de
exportación del petróleo ruso en 60
dólares por barril también nos acompaña
en nuestra mesa de trabajo nuestra
cronista de economía Daniel holandón
Daniela bienvenida muy buena mañana de
lunes una noticia que estábamos
esperando y que estábamos adelantando la
semana pasada y ahora sí saludamos a
nuestra primera invitada al día Ella es
la doctora aribel Contreras Suárez
analista de asuntos globales y
coordinadora de licenciatura de negocios
globales de la Universidad
iberoamericana de Ciudad de México
aribel como siempre Un gusto tenerla con
nosotros en nuestro programa directo a
América
Raúl como siempre Un gusto para mí poder
estar contigo Muy buenos días Muy buenos
días y por supuesto vamos a analizar
entonces estas implicaciones del embargo
al petróleo ruso que también afectan a
la Unión Europea afectan a occidente
Cuál es su primera lectura aribel
que es Rusia quien está cerrando la
válvula del gas natural pero ahora del
petróleo pero por también por el otro
lado vemos que la Unión Europea Estados
Unidos Australia sobre todo el g7 se ha
sumado a esta propuesta que desde hace
tres meses se teje finamente para
analizar de manera quirúrgica Hasta qué
punto se puede poner un techo es decir
un tope máximo para adquirir al petróleo
ruso que son los sesenta dólares por
barril y en caso que el precio
internacional
descienda por debajo de los sesenta
dólares Entonces los países pondrán como
tope un cinco por ciento por debajo de
algún nuevo tope es decir Raúl estamos
viendo que ahorita estos países no van a
aceptar pagar más por barril que
provenga de Rusia y también están
sancionando aquellas navieras o aquellas
empresas que aseguren el barril que
únicamente lo puedan transportar en que
siempre y cuando demuestren que se está
pagando como máximo este precio que
estoy señalando Raúl Ariel muy buenos
días Sí yo quiero preguntarle como para
traer la noticia un poco hacia nuestra
región y hacia el resto del mundo esto
que impactó va a tener directamente
sobre los precios del petróleo y
teniendo en cuenta también que ayer la
OPEP más se reunió y decidió mantener el
Grifo medio cerrado para darle como
estabilidad a esos precios altos del
petróleo
saludarte Daniela y me parece muy
pertinente este planteamiento que pone
sobre la mesa porque en la región de
América Latina y el Caribe No olvidemos
que hay grandes productores y
exportadores del petróleo como son
México y Venezuela Parece ser que estos
dos países no están Sabiendo Cómo
aprovechar la coyuntura es decir por el
lado de México no estamos Sabiendo ser
grandes jugadores Aunque somos miembros
de lopep diez México no ha podido
despuntar ni figurar como debería de ser
y Venezuela al menos de lo que se saben
los medios internacionales es que no le
está costando y no está Sabiendo mover
bien sus cartas con respecto a Estados
Unidos sabemos que ahí hubo un un
acuerdo con la empresa Chevron pero creo
yo que pudiera moverse todavía más Para
aprovechar esta coyuntura algo
importante a a destacar Es que hoy
empieza ya este
este acuerdo entra en vigor se cocinó
desde hace tres meses atrás y la
respuesta por parte de Rusia es que es
Rusia quien decide cerrar los oleoductos
es quien decide no comerciar con estos
países que se están sumando a aprovechar
estos este tope de dólares sin embargo
algo otro punto importante destacar es
que esta Cumbre eh Daniela que que el
día de ayer se reúnen decidieron no
bajar más aún la producción anual o
mensual porque se esperaba que podían
decidir bajar más aún la producción lo
cual generaría que hay menos oferta a
nivel mundial y Por ende los precios
internacionales Se podrían disparar algo
que no sería buenas noticias para
occidente pero que generó cierto aliento
porque esto significa que no están
jugando tanto con el mercado
internacional como se ha venido
generando durante las últimas
a nivel también han dicho que ese tope
de 60 dólares no es suficiente porque a
Rusia producir un barril le cuesta entre
30 y 40 dólares y para mantener sus
finanzas entre 60 y 70 dólares que lo
venda es un precio bueno por qué no
fueron más allá en en esta medida
claro Daniel estamos viendo que los
intereses geo
políticos y miembros de la ope pues se
mueven una balanza donde tienen ellos
por un lado que evaluar hasta dónde
bajar la oferta para aumentar el precio
internacional pero también occidente
tiene que evaluar hasta dónde poner este
tope máximo porque en caso de que lo
bajara mucho más en con una intención de
estrangular la economía rusa pues
entonces lo único que se generaría es
que Rusia puede decidir dejar de
producir una gran cantidad de de
barriles Y entonces en automático como
efecto pivote se dispararía el precio
Entonces ha sido una medida muy Por eso
yo decía una exploración quirúrgica por
parte de occidente pero también
está haciendo lo propio y sobre todo
hace lo propio de diplomacia energética
al interior de la OPEP puesto que es
miembro de la OPEP más es decir op más
convierte se convi un grupo de 23
naciones donde Rusia se ha convertido en
un gran actor y donde Arabia Saudita
como líder de esta de este grupo Pues no
ha accedido a las peticiones de
occidente Daniela también yo le quiero
preguntar si con esto también de alguna
manera se puede desestabilizar el
mercado de hidrocarburos no hasta qué
punto podría Rusia mantenerse así o si
podemos ver al kremlin exceder ante este
exigencia digamos por parte de occidente
no cuando Rusia dice Pues no yo quiero
que mi petróleo A lo mejor este más caro
o lo que sea que decidan también
occidente tendría las manos amarradas y
Y qué se puede hacer cuando haya digamos
este punto de tranca
claro Raúl y me parece muy interesante
tu pregunta porque estamos viendo que
Rusia está
redireccionando su lo que es su petróleo
hacia países como India como china
ahorita con china están construyendo ya
el segundo megaducto del primero que se
llama fuerza de Siberia probé una gran
cantidad de de petróleo Y entonces
estamos viendo cómo se está
reconfigurando es decir yo llamo una
nueva arquitectura energética donde los
precios internacionales compradores y y
vendedores están moviendo mucho este
tablero es principalmente de petróleo
pero no olvidemos Raúl que Rusia es un
gran proveedor sí de energético donde el
gas natural y el petróleo juegan un plan
estratégico como arma pero también Rusia
es un gran proveedor mundial de metales
y de granos entonces lo que no puede
hacer en un en un sector lo
promueve sus fichas en los otros
sectores entonces Hoy vemos la
importancia de los recursos naturales de
Rusia frente al mundo